[Music]
straight ahead
all law and crime daily a texas woman
convicted of brutally stabbing her
husband in bed
is let out of prison a look into the
prosecution of susan wright
the justice department officially closes
the tamir rice case saying no officers
will be charged
why the family of the 12 year old boy is
outraged we don't care if they were
consistently lying what we care about is
whether they were lying
and should a woman accused of attacking
a teen after wrongfully accusing him of
stealing her phone
face charges our experts weigh in
do you see two black people no i'm not
letting you walk away with my phone
plus two more officers involved in the
brianna taylor case
will be fired what their termination
means for justice for brianna
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a woman convicted of stabbing her
husband 193 times is now out of prison
law and crime's jesse webber has more on
the trial of susan wright
the texas woman who was convicted of
tying her naked husband to the bed and
stabbing him to death
was just released from prison a jury
found susan wright guilty of the 2003
murder of her husband jeff
and after serving 16 years behind bars
she was granted parole
this past summer true crime fans may
remember her 2004 trial
including the moment the state
re-enacted the vicious killing on a bed
she originally got 25 years in prison
then she was granted a new sentence of
20 years after it was determined her
attorneys provided
ineffective assistance as part of her
release she'll be under the super
intensive
supervision program and will be required
to check in until
2024. for long crime i'm jesse webber
joining me now is attorney dina dal
along with terry austin dina
susan wright is being released after
about 16 years but as you heard
still going to have superintendents of
parole for about three and a half years
wear an ankle bracelet and also do anger
management
thoughts on the conclusion of this saga
you know some people might wonder why
she's getting out so early
but parole is commonly like an
in-between step
between incarceration and freedom to
society
and like you said she's gonna have be
monitored she has four years while she's
going to be on parole she's going to
have intensive
anger management counseling she'll be
supervised she won't be
she'll be monitored with this ankle
bracelet it may give a chance for her to
be rehabilitated in a way that when she
does enter society freely
in four years we're hoping that she will
be
no longer a menace to society no terry
193 stabs in a failed self-defense
argument
what's your take on wright being
released to parole
you know i think that 16 years is not
nearly enough for such a brutal and
heinous crime
you know under texas law she could have
received life in prison instead you know
she got 25 years
which was ultimately reduced on appeal
and you know i think that it is an
injustice for the family
who you know have now no father
so there are two children involved here
so i think it's a
really bad outcome absolutely obviously
keep eyes on how her parole is going
the justice department officially closes
the investigation into the shooting
death of tamir rice by cleveland police
without filing charges
anjanan levy spoke with the attorney for
rice's family about this development
this news was not completely unexpected
as it had been reported
previously by the new york times and the
washington post
but it was disappointing nonetheless to
tamir rice's family
they did not treat the
rice family or samaria rice tamir's
mother
well here they did not they didn't
communicate their decision
they engaged in a highly irregular
process where they apparently overruled
the recommendations of career
prosecutors
they delayed the decision by months and
months and months
until the statute of limitations expired
and now it has
tamir rice was shot by cleveland police
officer timothy lohmann in a park in
2014.
tamir had an airsoft gun two officers
mistook
for a real gun the attorney for rice's
family received a report from the doj
that he calls superficial and a
whitewash of the incident
sabode chandra is particularly angry
that he and tamir's mother
learned of the decision from the media
and not the doj
the new york times and washington post
had previously reported that career
prosecutors
wanted to convene a grand jury but were
overruled by doj higher-ups
there's no acknowledgement in there
there's no response to our inquiry about
did career prosecutors as the new york
times and washington post reported
did career prosecutors in fact recommend
the convening of a grand jury
they don't address that at all how the
justice department
can't see that an officer who
killed a child and claimed that he was
shouting out commands from a moving
vehicle
when his fellow officer says the windows
were rolled up on a winter day
how does that story make any sense how
can that story be true
chandra would like to see obstruction
and perjury charges filed against those
two police officers
he says once he receives more
information from the department of
justice he would like to present that
information to both the county
prosecutor
and ohio's attorney general for law and
crime daily i'm angenette levy
expected but disappointing dina one of
the reasons the doj
stated for not pursuing charges was that
the video was grainy and the angles on
the camera
weren't that great what do you make of
that reasoning
i mean it's true and that is the problem
all along is that there wasn't
very much evidence but that was why the
career prosecutors were trying to
convene this grand jury
they wanted to know whether or not the
prosecutor police officer had made
statements that were basically
lies during that investigation and they
were hoping these obstruction charges
they could then use to create the civil
rights
charges that they were ultimately trying
to see if they could get
so and and it took two years before the
department of justice denied those queer
prosecutors
so there's there appears to be this you
know delay
this appearance of bias which is really
a shame because the whole reason why the
department of justice got involved
was to be an impartial unbiased
second investigation of the local
investigation and yet again
the family and a lot of people feel like
justice wasn't served here
okay and those delays affected the case
as the statute of limitation has passed
as the defense attorney said
terry the doj said that there was no
violation of rice's rights against
unreasonable force and that the officers
weren't willful in their violations of
his rights
do you agree i don't agree in fact i
agree with dina here
you know the system failed tomorrow
right the fact that the 9-1-1
system call was wrong the local
authorities didn't bring charges the
department of justice now
is not bringing charges and i go back to
the video it took
only two seconds for the police to start
shooting
that is not enough time i think that
there was unreasonable force here
and i think that there should be charges
brought against these police officers
exactly that two seconds was a cry out
for many people
to bring justice for tamir rice but of
course as we see that has not happened
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily why two more officers
involved in the brianna taylor case
will now be fired but first a prominent
jazz musician says his son was attacked
after being falsely accused of stealing
an iphone
will anyone face charges find out after
the break
charges could be coming for a woman who
allegedly wrongfully accused a 14 year
old of stealing her iphone
grammy award winner canyon harold filmed
the confrontation
in the arlo hotel lobby harold says he
and his son were accosted by the woman
who insisted that his son stole her
iphone the woman in the video was heard
saying
he's he's not leaving until he's proven
otherwise
afterwards the woman's uber driver
reportedly returned her iphone
the nypd says they're considering
bringing charges of grand larceny or
attempted robbery
a decision that came after viewing the
video
this is my phone number you don't have
to explain nice to her
that's mine are you kidding me you feel
like there's only one
one iphone made in the world no okay
then show me this no
you get to get a life over there you
better go use fine
find my iphone go do that find my iphone
is off
no no you can't no i'm the manager of
the hotel i don't care
this is my son hey did you see me just
come downstairs
i'm trying to help no but you're not
helping me is disrespectful no i'm
trying to settle this situation
my son
get on
no i'm not letting him walk away with my
phone please get my phone back i can't
i cannot
the recording ends abruptly and harold
says he and his son were assaulted
this is what happened he was definitely
assaulted
in front of the hotel in the front
i'm a trumpet player so now my hands
bleeding cause i'm trying to protect my
son because of a crazy person saying she
took his iphone
and trying to go into his pocket trying
to go into my pockets um this is
unacceptable unacceptable on a day when
i'm just trying to have a good time with
my son
right here so unacceptable
tina this one beyond a simple mistake i
think at one point
she's saying take off the case that's my
phone uh what are your thoughts about
the potential
for charges here well they have located
this woman so i think she will
definitely get
charged and there's assault a battery
maybe attempted larson
illegal detainment possibly because it
seems like they're trying to get away
and she
continues to try to stop them i mean
it's horrible to watch
so they say though in new york said that
they may not be being biased charges
i think there should be some sort of
biased charges it's clear here
that she's doing there's some racial
undertone here
no terry i practice here in new york
what i'm seeing here there's a potential
for attempted robbery or grand larceny
these charges
could come up to being more than four
years in jail do you think the charges
though fit what you've seen and heard so
far
here's what i think we should throw the
book at her
i do think that we should have attempted
robbery grand larceny
false imprisonment and you know this is
a biased crime
until people become accountable for
their actions
and until the criminal justice system
actually
really prosecutes these people and and
give them the maximum amount
i don't think we're going to be able to
stop this sort of thing from happening
so once the punishment fits the crime i
think people
will think twice about accusing people
unfoundedly
when they obviously had nothing to do
with taking
this woman's phone it was lost yeah and
of course the
the dina would you make that whole
comment well to find my iphone app
and it was off and that's point and
that's my phone that's my phone i mean
shout out to my mom when she first heard
that she's like
why didn't anyone just call her number
she would have known that's not her
phone
it made no sense what did you think dina
i think oftentimes in these kind of
situations whether or not it has to do
with this
or again with the police shooting that
we just saw recently
it doesn't make sense the circumstances
don't make sense unless you
allow the fact that there is some racism
involved because clearly this doesn't
make sense and it doesn't unless you
realize that
that has to be a motive for her wanting
to accuse
this perfect stranger and a lobby of a
hotel of something like this
yeah very bizarre thanks for the input
dina and uh terry
when we come back louisville police move
to fire two detectives
involved in the brianna taylor case why
the police chief is notifying them a
decision
10 months after the deadly rain
[Music]
the louisville police chief is now
planning to fire two of the officers
involved in the deadly warrant
on brianna taylor's apartment
chief yvette gentry sent a
pre-termination letter to the detective
who filed for the no knock warrant
briana taylor was killed in march
by police inside her home detective
joshua james was notified of violations
for failing to complete a search warrant
operations plan and lying about
contacting a u.s
postal inspector which he claimed in the
warrant that taylor's ex-boyfriend had
been receiving packages
at her apartment her ex-boyfriend
jamarcus glover reportedly hadn't been
to her apartment for months
officers arrested glover a convicted
drug dealer 40 minutes before the raid
on taylor's apartment
the chief wrote james had actually
received the information about the
postal inspector
from sergeant john mattenly one of the
officers who fired shots
in taylor's apartment the chief said
mattley got the information from another
officer
also receiving a pre-termination letter
detective miles cosgrove
investigators determined cosgrove fired
the bullet that killed taylor
james and cosgrove will have the
opportunity to appear at an
administrative hearing to contest their
findings
terry in this lie to get the warrant we
haven't heard where it originated from
mattley supposedly heard it from another
officer aren't there criminal charges
for lying to a judge to get a warrant
where are they now
absolutely they should bring charges
against this police officer
if in fact this is a lie i mean it's bad
enough that a woman was
killed they shouldn't have been there if
it had been a mistake
that's horrible but this is even worse
there was a lie involved so
we should be seeing charges brought
against at least mattingly if in fact he
was the one
who's involved in the lie and you know
the really hard part about this case is
not one of the officers really has been
charged as far as her death is concerned
so it just gets worse brian
exactly dina it appears in louisville
officers can get fired for lying about a
warrant
charged for shooting holes into an
apartment but not charged in the murder
of brianna taylor
could this termination change that
though
i think so there were two very important
determinations one is that there was a
lie to the court which is a fraud
to the court you know we can get
disbarred as lawyers for that so
the fact that a police officer for this
long was still acting like a police
officer after this is actually quite
shocking
and there could easily be a perjury
charge for that officer jane that was
just fired
and the other officer involved you know
was considered reckless
in his shooting and there's been so many
really detailed reenactments and
interviews
and the amount of evidence i think is
just compiling larger and i think we
might see charges against
him as well now terry hear me out this
is where i get confused here and quote
unquote confused
when my clients step into a situation
like like a petty
larceny or something like that and one
of the people pulls out a knife
everyone's charges get bumped up
so if officer mattley and cosgrove lie
to get this warrant and someone
dies because of it how come officers
charges can't get risen as well
they should be you were absolutely right
brian i mean
you have to wonder if it's because they
are police officers
and obviously we know that there's some
sort of sovereign immunity here some
sort of limited immunity
but the fact is you know there are lies
involved here
and they should have charges because
what occurred to brianna taylor the fact
that she was killed
no one has been held accountable for
that and you know just
so far we only have charges as they
relate to hankinson and it has to do
with
the neighbors for endangering the
apartment next door
that's not enough here this resulted in
the death of an individual
and someone needs to pay for that yeah
not only the death of brianna taylor but
also these officers put other officers
in danger
by their own lies that's reckless
endangerment of their colleagues and the
innocent people in the home
that they raided we'll wait to see if
charges come up though but i wouldn't
hold my breath here
when we come back a wrestler dies after
being caught in a rip current in the
ocean
his body found days later why his widow
is now suing
next
[Music]
the widow of a wwe star is suing los
angeles county
over his drowning death wrestler sean
gaspard died in may
after being caught in a rip current
while swimming at venice beach
with his 10 year old son the lawsuit
alleges lifeguard sargus
gaspard and his son struggling in the
water but failed to act quickly
then when they did come the lawsuit
accuses them of only helping the child
and leaving gaspard
in the water to die rescuers at the time
told local media that gaspar told them
to save his son first
cruz found his body three days later
dina this story really breaks my heart
in many ways
but telling the lifeguards to save his
son first
isn't the first heroic thing gaspard has
done he also stopped an armed robbery in
florida back in 2016
but my question here is is the fact that
he told the lifeguards to save his son
first could that affect
his civil case i mean it's possible i
think this is going to be a very hard
case for him to prove
unfortunately you know the pacific ocean
is known for surfing right so our waves
here
are very dangerous and we have them have
a lot of riptide and i remember actually
that weekend because it was right around
the time
that the stay-at-home order listed and
people were allowed to visit the beaches
again
and it happened to correspond with very
difficult rip tides
and so i there were quite a few of
rescues around that time
and so unfortunately we do have um
occasional drownings
in the la area and our l.a county
department is known for the one of their
fastest response times for the life
department
so i the lifeguards i think this is
going to be very difficult for him to
prove
i've seen them rescue more than one
person at a time in the ocean so
my guess is that they were probably far
apart
otherwise i think they probably would
have rescued both the son and him
at the same time just from my you know
knowledge of kind of how they
tend to operate here but this is going
to be hard
for them to prove because like i said
they have a very good reputation
they encounter this kind of thing
unfortunately
quite a bit dana thank you for both your
expertise in the courts and
in the waters uh in other news in the
sporting world a former olympic boxer
has been charged in the murder of his
daughter
twenty-five-year-old ola salman's body
was found in a park in staten island new
york
last year she was known for volunteering
at a domestic violence shelter for
muslim women and children
after her death her father khabari
salaam told the new york times
she had told him about being followed by
someone on the highway
but now more than a year later police
say her father strangled her
dragged her body into the woods and
covered it with branches
officials say salaam left the country
after her death and was extradited from
kuwait
terry i know you felt outraged when you
heard this story
tell us why you know brian that's right
i felt really that this case is just so
difficult to
understand it's disturbing because a
child is supposed to trust their parent
and here we have a father who is
powerful
in strength and he allegedly strangled
his daughter and then he
tried to conceal her body he lied about
the fact
that someone might have been following
her
when he knew apparently all along that
he was the one who
actually killed her and you know
according to the reports brian
there was a restraining order issued
against him
so we know that there were some issues
with the
family and as far as the relationship
was concerned
between the father and the daughter so i
also
am disturbed because they did not follow
up with that to make sure
that she was safe and you know at the
end of the day the
irony is she worked at a women's
domestic violence shelter so she helped
other women who had to deal with
domestic violence and so
here she is dying in a violent way at
the hands of her own father
i mean it's really heartbreaking that we
know that we can't bring back someone's
life but the hope is that her
life and memory continue to protect
other women in her situation
terry and dina thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here at law and
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you